[Music]
now to a special report from the 8 news
now i-team a husband enters a local
hospital for a medical procedure so why
did his wife die just outside vanessa
murphy has been looking into this tragic
death and how changes have been made so
this never happens again
gee whiz was the song that she sang and
that was also one of the things that
attracted me to
her voice david litt recalls a classmate
named lear singing at a talent show back
in the early 60s so i called her
and we started dated from there they
became high school sweethearts once you
meet her
you wouldn't forget her marriage and his
enlistment in the military followed in a
tour in vietnam and today as a veteran
david receives medical care at the v.a
in august of 2020 he went in for a
transfusion he says lear didn't drive
much due to health issues but she wanted
to go with her husband so she dropped
him off parked the car and tried to head
inside but she was turned away they
allowed her to come in to tell me that
she couldn't come in
and that's when i gave her my phone
said okay
i'll call you
find out
how you're doing there was a no visitor
policy at the emergency department at
the time due to the pandemic i think
that could have been handled a lot
differently lear was 75 years old the
temperature on record for that day as
high as 110. still lear went to wait in
the car in the parking lot that was
around 9 30 around noon a doctor on
their way in saw her in the car which
wasn't running with the windows rolled
down she said she didn't have much gas
so she couldn't let the car run but to
david that doesn't sound quite right one
thing i
made a habit of never getting below half
a tank of gas then around 2 30 after
david tried calling lear and there was
no answer he asked hospital staff to
check on her shortly after he heard an
announcement rapid response in the
parking lot lear was found unresponsive
in the car
her body temperature 109. throwing doing
compressions
and i i'm across the hall from where
this has taken place but i knew it was
her
without even seeing i knew it was her
lear was pronounced dead inside the
hospital her cause of death hyperthermia
the unfortunate reality was we had spent
so much time on
risk assessing protect veterans protect
staff
and after that incident occurred we had
to take a step back and say well
there's a secondary risk too because of
the weather out here william caron is
the head of v.a southern nevada health
care system a policy is a policy
but with the heat and this was an
elderly woman
with a limp with her own health issues
she wasn't a veteran
but do you think a mistake was made at
the people who interacted with her at
the door
yeah i think we could go back in time
hindsight and
review every single detail but to say
that someone was was malicious or
reckless i wouldn't say that in the
least the the goal
was the greater good of protecting all
veterans
multiple departments at the v.a
investigated the incident the i-team's
request for the results of the
investigations were denied while we've
appealed we also asked karen about this
but any of those results of the
investigation typically that's not
something that we would share
outright were you aware that there was
further investigation no
it's the first time
that
i'm hearing this karen says policy was
changed the day lear died to allow one
visitor to accompany a patient and to
increase patrols in the parking lot were
you aware that they changed policy after
that
no
it will help someone else if it gets if
the same situation arises but it's not
helping me at all david says for now
he's trying to get used to life without
his wife of 57 years by his side i know
it's going to take time vanessa murphy
live local now
there are still unanswered questions
surrounding lear lit's death the va
first received the i-team's formal
request for information on the first of
february
now three months later the va has not
fulfilled that request